austin is with us austin is in
portland oregon hey austin how are you
hey dave hey john uh i'm in some
desperate need here of some uncle david
right
i've got an hoa for my town house
that we're voting on a special
assessment
and it it's it's up for vote in the next
week or two
and they're they're trying to charge
each uh
each owner 27 000
for uh repairs for drywall
dry rot and mold
i'm at a little bit of a loss as to what
to do or how to deal with this
i'm skeptical of the honesty of the hoa
um i don't know the contractor obviously
um i talked to the hoa the
the head guy over there yesterday and he
told me
my best bet would be to try to contact
my insurance
today and try to get special assessment
insurance
and they'll probably cover it that
sounds like
insurance fraud to me if i've ever heard
it and
it it hasn't gone through yet but it's
up for vote
and i don't know if i need to hit the
campaign trail
and talk to my neighbors or
if there's anything i can do about this
well there's two problems um
one problem if it's all true and one
problem if it's not
and so there's you know you got if you
got the if the place is falling down
and you got dry rot and you got to fix
it if you don't fix it the whole car the
whole thing is going to go down in value
and you're going to lose your property
value
um and the fact that it's gone this far
without somebody
starting repairs before they got this
far behind
means that they've mismanaged it at a
minimum
so new hoa
officers and management company come on
board recently
uh it was i don't know how long ago it
was before i lived here
and i lived here three years okay no so
they just suddenly woke up and realized
the place is rotting down
this is so strange look there's been an
ongoing lawsuit
um i think it's been going on just
before i
i had moved in a few years back lawsuit
by who
um it was the lawsuit the hoa sued the
original contractor
for negligence and they got 500
000 from that but the bid is 1.7 million
the hoa also has 200 000 in reserves
that they tell me they can't legally use
for this because it's not an a
foreseeable issue like a roof or
you know some kind of foreseeable
maintenance was this disclosed when you
bought the place they should have
disclosed you were in the middle of a
lawsuit
and like you would have a claim there
i was not told but
it i'm sure it may have been in in the
bottom line of the last page of some
paperwork that i signed you know i'm
gonna check i'm gonna change tactics
here let me tell you what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna sell this piece of crap and go
somewhere else
yeah you you this is clowns to the left
to meet jokers to the right
you ain't gonna get out of this it's a
circus
either the place is rotting down and or
there's a crooked contractor involved
and or an hoa that's mismanaging
or some combination of all this nothing
in this whole deal sounds like it's
gonna
i mean if you get in there and you spend
you're gonna spend an enormous amount of
energy auditing
all of their books and auditing their
processes and making sure that they're
competent and that this contractor is
not the
brother-in-law of the manager of the hoa
and you know you're not getting screwed
somewhere there you're going to spend an
amazing amount of energy
pushing back against the tide here
only to end up with a fixed semi-rotted
townhouse after it's all said and done
so you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
sell it
let them screw with it these idiots let
me run just run and once they fix it you
still got the same
people leading right yeah you're still
got i mean run they're gonna knock on
your door next month
run that's exactly what i would do
and i hate hoas this is the dave ramsey
show